وقال مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي في بيان
حصلت الجزيره عليه اللا حل عسكريا في
السودان دعيا الى وقف القتال فورا دون
شروط مسبقه البيان اضاف ان القتال في
السودان سببه اختلاف الرؤى بشان الاتفاق
الايطالي الموقع في ديسمبر الماضي ودع
المجلس لادخال المدنيين كطرف ثالث في
المفا
وضات في الحرب التي تس
ببت الف شخص حتى التاسع من الشهر الجاري
حسب البيان واكد المجلس على ضروره تاسيس
اليات للرقابه والتحقق من وقف اطلاق النار
وحمايه المنشات الحيويه للمدنيين مثل مطار
الخرطوم واشار مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي
الى ان وقف اطلاق النار في السودان خلال
الفتره الماضيه لم يتم احترامه بشكل كبير
وان تاثيره كان محدودا على المدنيين
وفي ردود الافعال قال مصدر دبلوماسي
سوداني للجزيره ان بلاده ابلغت الاتحاد
الافريقي بانها ستنسحب من عضويته اذا تم
اتخاذ خطوات دون تشاور معها المصدر اضاف
ان السودان احبط خطه لعقد مؤتمر قمه لدول
الايجاد في الثاني عشر من ايار مايو
الجهري لان الامر تم دون التشاور مع
الخرطوم حسب قوله
مجلس السلم والامن الافريقيه تابع للاتحاد
الافريقي وهو يشبه الى حد ما مجلس الامن
الدولي ويتولى تنفيذ قرارات الاتحاد وفيما
يلي نبذه عن مهام وصلاحيات المجلس
[موسيقى]
معنا من مقر الاتحاد الافريقي في اديس
ابابا مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق حسن اذا في
اي اجواء ينعقد هذا الاجتماع لمجلس الامن
والسلم الافريقي وابرز الجوانب التي يركز
عليها
بالفعل سهام قبل قليل بدا الاجتماع الموسع
لمجلس السلم والامن الافريقي عبر تقنيه
الكونفرنس طبعا مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي على مستوى الرؤساء والرؤساء
الدول والرؤساء الحكومات هو اعلى السلطه
في الاتحاد الافريقي وقراراته نافذه على
كافه الدول الافريقيه بالاضافه الى ان يتم
الاسترشاد بها في كافه المنظمات الدوليه
والاقليميه لاسيما الامم المتحده وبالتالي
المفوضيه الافريقيه تريد ان تتحصل على
قرارات وتوصيات استراتيجيه من هذا المجلس
رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه سوف يلقي بيانا
كاملا حول تفاصيل ورؤيه الاتحاد الافريقي
لحل الازمه السودانيه طبعا هناك اشكاليه
كبيره لازاله تواجه الاتحاد الافريقي وهي
تعدد المبادرات وجهود الوساطه والتي بدات
بحسب مراقبين في الاتحاد الافريقي تتنافس
احيانا وان كانت كلها تريد ان تحل المشكله
وبالتالي من اولى من اولى البنود التي سوف
يتم مناقش هو تاسيس مجموعه اتصال دوليه
يتم فيها ضم كافه الاطراف المعنيه سواء
الاليه الثلاثيه الاليه الرباعيه جمع
الدول العربيه دول ايجاد كلها تحتها مسمى
واحد مجموعه اتصال الدوليه يقودها الاتحاد
الافريقي حتى
لا يكون هناك مجال لطرفي الصراع لاختيار
مبادره من هنا هناك وبالتالي هذا هو
البندل الرئيسي
والمهم في هذا الاجتماع ايضا الاتحاد
الافريقي يريد ان يتحدث عن رؤيته للحل
هناك خطه لخفض التصعيد تتكون من سته نقاط
من وقف فوري الى اطلاق النار المساعده
الانسانيه محاكمه او مساعده المرتكبين
للجرائم وهناك خطط اخرى وبالتالي تتحدثي
سوف يطرح هذه الرؤيه للحصول على موافقات
من مجلس السلم الامريكي طبعا هناك ايضا
دول الجوار مشاركه في هذا
الاجتماع باعتبارها هي المتاثره طبعا سهام
الاتحاد الافريقي حتى هذه اللحظه لا زال
[موسيقى]
وهو اجتماع رؤساء الدول والحكومات
الافريقيه سهام
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من اديس ابابا